we just do a quick sound check Casey
would you for breakfast this morning uh
honey I'm curious
obviously honey hot seriousiy breakfast
of champions
all right barely one second more at this
altitude
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking and I all
see the personal question now it is soon
I must - a deep organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by Vimeo Pro which is the
ideal video hosting platform for
entrepreneurs and in fact a bunch of my
startups already use Vimeo Pro including
wealthfront who uses it to explain how
wealthfront works TaskRabbit uses it to
tell their company's story and there are
many other names you would recognize
among their customers
Airbnb Etsy etc why do they use it well
Vimeo Pro provides enterprise level
video hosting for a fraction of the
usual cost features include gorgeous
high quality playback with no ads up to
20 gigabytes of video storage every week
unlimited plays and views and a fully
customizable video player which can
include your logo custom outro etc you
also get VIP support and you get all of
this for just $1.99 per year that's 17
dollars a month with no complicated
bandwidth calculations or hidden fees
and you can try it risk-free for 30 days
so check it out Vimeo comm forward slash
business that's VI m EO com forward
slash business and use promo code Tim to
get 25% off that's a special discount
just for you guys so check it out Vimeo
com forward slash business promo code
Tim
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers
whether they are chess prodigies hedge
fund managers celebrities like the Gavin
Arnold Schwarzenegger or say legendary
music producers like Rick Rubin anyone
in between military artistic you name it
there are patterns that you can tease
out and it is my job to try to find the
routines the habits the favorite books
the meals the timing everything that you
can apply from their life to your own to
develop your own skills to develop your
own version of success both in your
personal and professional lives and this
episode is no exception I had the chance
to chat with Casey nice tat we've been
trying to get together for a very long
time Casey is a fascinating filmmaker he
would also call himself a youtuber and
if you look for his name on the
interwebs Casey nice tat any I sta t
he's also at Casey Neistat on Twitter
you find headlines like the following
from Adweek help filmmaker casey neistat
gets away with murder that was the
headline and talked about how he
effectively took a budget that Nike gave
him and used it to travel around the
world with his friend and then had Nike
thank him for it another headline from
Teen Welfare dad to YouTube icon both
accurate next headline Casey nice that
can pretty much do anything that he
wants as you see the pattern here and
it's it's a very fascinating story
because Casey has done the opposite of
what a lot of people feel you should do
in other words he was a very popular
indie director had won all sorts of
awards Sundance popular on HBO has a
wall full of awards and moved to
self-publishing on the Internet instead
right now both most people look at say
going on YouTube as a starting point to
stair-step to more traditional media and
distribution heated the opposite he's a
high school dropout and we met through a
very good friend of mine named Sepp at
the MIT Media Lab and we cover a lot we
cover his history we cover overcoming
adversity we
about his decision to vlog that has put
out one video per day and how that
decision made his popularity explode
he's a he's a quirky guy he's a he's
very well known for running so we talked
about the physical aspect of his life he
still makes a lot of his own props and
there are lots of questions I wanted to
ask for instance you know if you are
able to charge five six figures maybe
more for product placement YouTube
videos why on earth would you start yet
another company a start-up a tech
startup it's a fascinating guy I love
his work and I hope you enjoyed this
conversation as much as I enjoyed it say
hello to Casey at Casey Neistat CA se y
NE is t-80 and without further ado
please enjoy my conversation with Casey
nice step
Kaycee welcome to the show great to be
here I have had so many requests from my
fans to connect with you and of course
we have many mutual friends Ryan holiday
SEP cam var very old buddy of mine among
others and I'm a fan of your work so
thanks for making the time yeah it's
great to it's great to finally speak I
feel like you and I have tried to
actually connect physically on the phone
I think there was a text back and forth
at one point in time so it's nice to
finally uh it's nice to finally hear
your voice I think it's it's fated to
happen you know things connect when
they're intended to connect on some
level and that having been said you are
in New York City and just Ted it would
seem like the the entire squad squadron
of police cars from NYPD pull up outside
your house this isn't like the
professional or anything is there any
any any catastrophe pending outside of
your that's oh no no no and and I warned
you of that before we started recording
just to let you know that when you hear
sirens in the background or whatever it
might be not to be alarmed but I think
one of them one of the biggest battles
for me
of being a filmmaker making movies in
New York City for 15 years now has been
figuring out how to navigate the
incessant noise pollution that is
downtown Manhattan um and to paint a
little picture for your audience my my
office is on the second floor facing
Broadway so that means it's not the
exact height of all the exhaust pipes so
these really loud buses that drive by
and I have single pane windows so um I
will try my best but if you if you hear
what sounds like some sort of battle
taking place in the background know that
everything's fine that's just New York
City I remember very distinctly this one
night when I was working on my TV show
and we had to do voiceovers we had to do
pickup lines and we were filming I'm not
going to name the hotel but at in a
hotel room in New York City that was on
the third or fourth floor at a very busy
intersection and literally every time I
got 3/4 of the way through any line we
tried this at two different times during
the day we had to start over and over
and it was just the most maddening
experience imaginable but the how do you
contend with that actually we'll start
there because I remember this joke that
someone told me about audio and they
said you know why does thunder come
after lightening it because even God has
to wait for audio and is that a is that
one of the biggest challenges of working
in New York City are there other
challenges that people might not be
aware of
um I mean that's probably the most like
tactile that's that's probably easiest
to point to but I'd say like um to
digress here it's it's more than just
the battle that is recording audio for
films that this is noise pollution in
New York City but my wife and I moved to
to Tribeca we actually live on Broadway
in New York City and the the grumbling
of a garbage truck or cement mixer or a
bus I I've become so sensitive to that I
freaked out when it goes by my wife has
to tell me to calm down and it's one of
the biggest reasons why I want to leave
the city now after 15 years is it's just
it's a noise that it's not just a noise
like lightning or I mean like thunder or
loud music it's a noise that just kills
all other noises so it's like this black
cloud of sound that prevents any
communication or conversation or human
interaction it just destroys everything
and it wrecks my world and I take it so
personally uh in here see you've been in
the city then for 15 years but you grew
up in Connecticut is that right yeah so
I lived in I was born and raised in
southeastern Connecticut and I always I
always sort of preface that by saying
I'm from the poor part of Connecticut
I'm from the shitty part of Connecticut
not Connecticut as always when people
think Connecticut they think Greenwich
and the fancy parts in Connecticut has
kind of another side to those tracks and
that's where I'm from and is it true
that you were on welfare at one point
because I was I was going to bring that
up later in the conversation but I've
read that and this is that is that true
and you drew it Ryan and I have talked
about your background and how
fascinating is but he told me that you
had dropped out of high school and then
I had read that you were on welfare but
I was hoping you could provide some
context around those kind of early years
yeah you know I I can't you know I had a
bite of troublesome like adolescence one
of four kids and my parents got divorced
when I was in I think a freshman in high
school and I think it's always a real
challenge for for any family but at that
age I think it's probably the most you
know I have a grown son now who's who's
a senior in high school and the freshman
in high school at 13 years old is such a
vulnerable age for young people and I
didn't cope very well with the issues
that were happening at home and I ran
away from home and moved in with this
girl and got her pregnant because that's
what teenagers do and you know I had a
kid my son was born two weeks after my
17th birthday
I mean I never I never went back home
after running away from home at age 15 I
never went to my parents for money um I
just kind of when I said I left home I
properly left home I never went back um
and yeah when when my kiddo was born we
were on welfare we got free let me think
what was it we have freedom milk and
then there was something else it's like
welfare is you get this it's it's get
this credit card that you can spend
money on on anything um and then you get
free milk in Navy free diapers I don't
really remember how it worked is a long
time ago certainly it was very helpful
at that time of my life and the how did
the bridge from that point to film come
about because I'm and we'll talk about
some some of your specific work but how
did that develop the sort of interest
and foray into filmmaking uh you know I
think that it's funny because it's him
that question itself is something that
I've only really been started to examine
in the last couple years of my career um
as people ask me more and more and
especially with the launch of my tech
company and looking back it I think it's
a pretty specific thing which is that it
has one of four kids like the middle
sort of Forgotten child
the youngest not the oldest not the girl
but the other one that was me so I
always was sort of the loudest to get
the most attention nobody paid attention
to me so my psychiatrist says anyways
and and I think like when my older
brother Van who I credit with getting me
into filmmaking when he showed me in
2000 or 1999 how the first iMac that big
blue bubbly looking on that thing how
you could edit video on that I just saw
something that really captured my
imagination and when I he and I edited
the very first thing I ever edited which
was taking my at the time baby son to
the zoo all of a sudden I saw this
opportunity to take what was an idea or
set of ideas that only existed in my
head and turn it into something tangible
turn it into something that I could then
share with people and for someone who
had spent my whole life then all 18
years of it 19 years of it feel like I
never had a voice
all the sudden via filmmaking I sort of
felt like I had a voice at a loudspeaker
that makes perfect sense
and from that from that feeling let's
let's flash forward for a second because
I really want to introduce people to
some of your work if they haven't seen
it before but could you talk about bike
lanes or make it count whichever came
first
yeah bike lanes came first but bike lane
is a really good example of that bike
lanes was probably there's only been a
how do I preface this people ask like
where do you come up with the ideas for
your movie and I always say like
whatever effects me whatever impacts me
whatever I care about is what I make a
movie about in bike lanes is a movie I
made in 2010 I think maybe it's 2011
wherein I was given a summons from a
police officer for riding my bike
outside of the bike lanes which for
starters it turns out is not an actual
infraction um but beyond that it really
frustrated me because I wasn't breaking
any laws and I felt I was doing
something that's completely just and I
think what most people would have done
is maybe gone to court and fought the
$50 summons and probably would have won
and wasted half of their day in the
process but I'd redirected my anger and
I made a movie that really express my
frustration but
did it in a somewhat sardonic way in
that movie went tremendously viral
online it was seen like five million
times in its first day and this is
before I had an audience on YouTube and
at one point in time Mayor Bloomberg
actually actually had to respond to a
question about the video in a press
conference
so yes Meza very that's a really literal
example of you know me being a
frustrated kid and wishing I had a way
for everyone to hear and a way to share
my frustrations and that movie is very
much so a compartmentalization of that
exact emotion and then outcome now in
concrete terms can you give people sort
of a visual though for what you at you
ended up doing in that film yeah so it's
very the Buster Barry Buster Keaton in a
way the cops argument was predicated on
this idea that the bike lanes were there
to keep you safe the bike lanes are for
cyclists I was riding outside of the
bike lanes therefore I was unsafe and
should be summons are given the summons
so I made a movie where just sort of
start to the beginning where I say the
cops and had to stay in the bike lane no
matter what and no matter what is is
underscored and I proceeded to ride my
bike around New York City crashing into
everything that is in the bike lanes
preventing people from actually cycling
safely within the lanes themselves and
that sort of crescendos when I when I
crash into a police car that was parked
in the middle of a bike lane so it was
something like that now the bike lanes
taking this frustration or
dissatisfaction and scratching your own
itch which segues nicely into tech and
we'll get to that also I mean almost all
the best founders I know are scratching
their own itch when they create a
product or a service I mean for instance
with the looking at the the iPod
batteries and whatnot have you have you
had a case where you vented frustration
in a public way that you regretted after
the fact or wish you'd handled
differently ah
regrets a strong word but one that I
look back on and sort of shake my head
was um I was very young when was this
I'm trying to come up with a year for
you to me I don't know but that's
probably 22 or something like that and I
was a I was a real I wasn't nobody then
so nobody knew who I was and I just made
a movie with my brother about bicycle
theft in New York City and they invited
us on morning local Morning News to to
talk about bike theft and they wanted us
to recreate a bike being stolen and we
showed up there and this woman who was
the the host of the morning of the
Morning News
was so rude to us because we were just
kids were two kids and show up early in
the morning she was so rude to us and so
mean to us and then she swore at her
intern in front of us and we're just
like my god this woman who does she
think she is
so we we kind of pranked her on air and
my brother pretended to cut cut me when
he was releasing the bike and this was I
want to say like maybe when YouTube had
just come out this is like so out of in
2005-2006 and that scene went crazy
crazy crazy viral and it's basically
this woman talking to camera about
what's taking place and here they are
demonstrating a bike lock and then all
of a sudden I start screaming and drop
the ground and squeeze cattle planets
all over myself and at no point time did
anyone especially the woman think that
it was real I'm not a very good actor
I'd ketchup packets all over me and my
brother was like shaking his head um but
her response is what got people so
excited she freaked out um I feel very
quickly turned into that werewolf that
was wearing it in turns earlier in the
day and in any event it became this huge
story it was all over the New York Post
and it was like uh you know they they
vilified her and it was whatever it was
what it was but looking back at it like
I'm not a huge fan of pranks I'm not a
huge fan at a laugh at someone else's
expense and I think so much of the
response to that was was out of context
like the world didn't know that this
that we that I was doing this because
this woman was mean to me the world just
saw me being kind of like a prankster
and that's an
and I don't like to project so the facts
that is miss contextualized I think is
sort of a silly was a silly that was the
the bike thief yeah not and not the
video itself just this little prank that
we pulled on air I think that it was it
sort of lacked the it lacked the
societal or cultural relevance of maybe
some of my other hippie movies that
definitely had a purpose this was much
more of Jessa just being a jerk
prankster kind of guy which is
definitely not how describe anything
else I've ever done in the ten year of
my career when when someone asks you
what do you do these days how do you
answer that I'm sure it depends on the
context but in general how do you
respond to that question I'm a youtuber
got it um you know used to say uh in my
Twitter bio that I'm Casey nice that
creator of the HBO series at one point
in time I said that I liked a word
winning filmmaker I don't think I gave
myself that title but others pert it's
not an inaccurate title and now and I
just take a big step back and I say what
and what how do I want to be identified
I think being a youtuber being sort of
being like every other kid on YouTube is
is maybe the most flattering flattering
context for me to live in
I like tech entrepreneur but this is
such a pretentious kind of stupid title
that if there were an easier way to say
that if there were less annoying way to
say tech entrepreneur I'd say that
that's it because 90% of my time is my
technology company and 10% is creating
YouTube videos but 90% of my efforts in
the tech company are internal facing and
not external facing and 100% of what I
do on YouTube go straight out to the
world so for all those reasons I
identify most as a youtuber and let's
let's talk about one of your most if not
the most correct me if I'm wrong popular
video on your YouTube channel which is
make it count is that still the most
popular I think so I don't know the one
I released when I released thirty-eight
minutes ago I hope gets more more views
than that but we'll see
um yeah and make it count is a really is
a really interesting case study Tim
because that was such an inflection
point in my career as a filmmaker uh you
know so historically I had directed
advertisements as as a many primary
means of income which is a really
convoluted unnecessarily complicated
somewhat ridiculous process where just a
tremendous amount of money is wasted at
the end of the day you turn out
something that is sort of creativity by
committee which is Murphy
invisible and just no one cares about
that's how I described 99% of all
advertising that's done in a firm HBO
fare when I was trying to figure out
what to do with my career I went to the
production company that represented me
the company that brought me my
advertising gigs and I said all I want
to do is make awesome videos put them on
the internet and then find companies
that will give me money to make awesome
videos like my other videos but I'll do
it for them
and my production company shook their
head at me and they said good luck it
will never work like that so I
immediately stopped working with them
and I went on my own I kind of went
rogue and somewhere in there Nike came
to me and I did this tiny project with
them which led to a larger project which
was a three a three movie a three
internet movie deal and the first two
movies were right down the line it was
there were what you'd expect I had big
big huge you know hundred million dollar
athlete sand them they were very well
received I loved making them but when it
came time to make the third movie I was
really burnt out from from the process
and at the ninth hour I called my editor
up and I said hey let's not make this
advertisement let's not make this movie
and said let's do something I've always
wanted to do which is let's just take
the entire production budget and travel
the world until we run out of money and
we'll record that we'll make some sort
of movie about that and he said you're
crazy but sure um it wasn't his ass it
was mine and that's that's exactly what
we did and make it count became this
video about running around the world and
sort of chasing after what matters to
you and that was the point that was the
message of the campaign was to make it
count was to make every moment in life
count so there was something sort of
poetic about the fact that
by us going rogue and taking this budget
and doing something more supposed to do
but that's something that narrative was
so perfectly in line with their
messaging that in the end we we had
something that they were tremendously
excited about and that was in a
maternity Morten because I haven't
checked on YouTube but that was Nikes
most watched video on on the internet
for a number of years and everyone was
really excited about the way that it
turned out what what did the phrasing
what was your phrasing in the first
phone call or email when you gave Nike
the heads-up on what you'd actually done
sure so a little context for you for
your listeners out there the the video
literally opens with scrolling text that
says Nike gave me a budget to make them
a commercial instead I blew the budget
traveling the world and that's literally
what happened so so some details around
that to color in what happened
specifically was like firstly this was
the smallest budget of all three budgets
for all three videos so this is the kind
of budget that I would say would be
equivalent to what Nike typically spends
on craft services what they typically
found snacks for one of their huge music
for one of their huge advertisement so
there wasn't that much accountability on
top of that they knew me they trusted me
and they weren't working with me because
they thought I could make them a perfect
TV commercial
then when working with me because they
wanted something different so I called
them before before I did this before I
took off and I said look I'm not going
to do the treatment um
treatments like a script I'm not going
to follow this be something different
and they said okay what do you even do I
said I don't know but I'm going to
travel and it's going to be great and
they just said like it was one executive
in particular named Alex Lopez he's
still at Nike and he's an incredible
creative genius and he was like Casey
just don't screw me over here I said I
was like Alex no promises but we're
gonna but we're gonna go and then we
were sort of like radio blackout for the
next for the next ten days
you know we how we did that movie and
you know we hit like whatever 15
countries and
in nine days but we had a girl here in
New York City and she was working pretty
much around the clock and she would get
an email from me from whatever internet
cafe I was in saying we want to go here
next and then true figure out how to
make it happen until until the money
dried up and when you were doing that I
mean you've done a fair amount of
traveling I mean did you do you have any
particular routines or tricks for
maintaining sanity or at least
minimizing completely burning yourself
out when following that type of schedule
um well firstly that type of schedule is
a unique type of schedule that is that
is like DEFCON one total chaos schedule
that's completely unsustainable
unrealistic and that I would advise no
human being on earth to ever attempt
that I'd like to add one detail to that
I did with my best friend Max and we
went it wasn't till our sixth night of
travel that we slept horizontally and
that's not like we were keeping track so
we were sleeping upright coach seats
either on airplanes or on buses like
going from from Zambia to to Kenya like
we just we never ever laid down and I
remember our our feet were so swelled
we're so swollen that we couldn't get
them into our shoes we just had these
big fat sullen feet so I recommend it
for no one that said I still travel
quite a bit and I a real expert when it
comes to traveling in Europe you're
someone who has probably defined what it
means to hack life better than anyone
else when it comes to traveling though I
think that I've got a really good grip
on where all the loopholes and shortcuts
are to really like remove the hate that
is a commercial aviation
could you give could you give people a
taste well sure and it's funny cuz you
tweeted earlier and I know you have a
video I saw I saw some fans link back to
it said I'd love for you to give a
little bit of color on that
um you tweeted earlier today what did I
ask Casey in our interview today and
somebody threw you back some something
negative about the movie I made about
how to give free upgrades or
my investors get angry because I only
fly first class and the truth is if you
fly enough you can really really crack
the whole system that is that is flying
commercial that said it's very important
to say this loud and clear if you don't
fly a ton if you don't if you don't
spend at least two hundred thousand
miles in the air a year which is that
which is about six times around the
earth if you don't do that none of these
tricks work these only work if you fly a
lot if you fly a lot and you fly with
one airline and you really climb to the
top of the heap which is airline status
you build a relationship you can almost
always ensure that you will get special
treatment and after flying a lot of kind
of makes sense like if you're the
airline why should you cater to a mass
audience that just goes on kayak in
search of the cheapest flights and then
jumps on a plane there's no loyalty
there there's nothing that incentivizes
someone to fly with you but someone like
me who spends ungodly amounts of money
flying and traveling every year of
course of course I want to court my
influence and my loyalty and that
courtship is something that you can
exploit to your own benefit and I guess
that's how I describe what it means the
hack hack commercial flight do you if
you're traveling and trying to travel
light but you're going to be recording
video what is your go-to gear what is
your go-to kit look like what type of
gear well I always I always travel light
it doesn't matter whether I'm going
somewhere for overnight you're going
somewhere for a month and a half I
always have the same setup which is one
small as big as it can possibly be well
still be a carry-on rolling suitcase and
then my backpack and all of my camera
gears in my backpack and my laptop and
all night everything else is in the
rolling suitcase but literally I can't
fit a pair of socks into my backpack so
I always have to have the second bag
with with the miscellaneous as in
clothing in it um but camera gear is
pretty cut-and-dry I I always have a
point-and-shoot and then I always have
an SLR what type of point-and-shoot an
SLR do you do you've currently favor
well I this is not by any means and
endorsement because I can talk at
nauseam about why this hardware is
absolutely terrible and everything's
wrong everything that's wrong with it
but it's my current favorite so again
this is not an endorsement in any
capacity but I currently use the Canon
70d as my main shooter including all my
vlogs and I do that because it's the
only one that has it has the best
autofocus technology of any SLR in the
market and when you're shooting with one
hand you can't be pulling focus so
that's why I use that and then my my
latest point in shoot is the Sony rx100
which has been great but there's some
reliability issues there which is
exactly what I expect from Sony is
reliability issues so what is still far
sore infection what is your what is your
post-production look like what are you
using - what are the tools that you use
for editing and post so I just use Final
Cut 10 which is really terrible software
it's just not great it's they're they're
very real reliability concerns around it
it almost feels like it's been
handicapped by Apple to appeal more to
the consumer and prosumer than the
professional market which is
antithetical to Final Cut 7 and every
previous iteration which is absolutely
professional editing software I think
they make this for for people that don't
consider themselves pros what a lot of
options so there are some benefits that
some detractions to that and I feel like
I've sort of maxed out what the what
this software is capable of and now I'm
really starting to feel the fact that
it's not it's not as capable as other
professional-grade editing software is
there is there any other software that
you use in addition to in addition to
that not really um you know I I'm all
about speed and efficiency I upload
every single day
so with that you you lack the
opportunity to spend a tremendous amount
of time color grading or bring into
After Effects to clean up or do the
kinds of things that technologies and
and software enable us to do I have much
less of an appreciation for what
technology can bring my work in much
more of an appreciation
Asian for for the craft storytelling in
in communicating ideas and sharing
messages which does not necessitate know
the kinds of things that technology
enable you to do today so looking at say
other people taking a stab at YouTube
what what are the biggest wastes of time
generally speaking in your mind or how
do novices waste the most time whether
it's in the filming stage or in post or
otherwise I mean I think it's much it's
less technical than anything else I
think that the the biggest waste of
energy and resources on on YouTube is
you see YouTube creators trying to copy
and be exactly like someone else and the
only thing that succeeds on YouTube are
people that are thinking outside the box
doing new things and I can talk about
that you know until until the cows come
home because it's something I believe in
so profoundly but you know YouTube is
built on originality and built on
unfounded genres and styles of content
creation you know I think 2011 YouTube
spent 200 million dollars sorry for that
sheathing looks like a diva black but
they sent they spent 200 million dollars
on giving these huge budgets to known
production entities that is like the
mtv's of the world and like LACMA for
example and all these big entities 200
million bucks they'd start YouTube
channels so original high quality
content would be made just for YouTube
and every one of them failed and at the
same time that they were failing those
200 million dollars were evaporating all
of these individuals all these young
people creating content that fit did no
categories came up on YouTube in a huge
way and now it's those creators those
original creators that are defining what
YouTube is they're defining it in a way
that does not exist inside any of the
norms of filmmaking in fact almost that
exception most of the successful content
creators on YouTube don't come from a
filmmaking background but instead
they've sort of they've they've like
metastasized what is a capability
elsewhere like a understand
elsewhere and they turned that into
success on YouTube Tyler Oakley was big
on tumblr he's a big blogger and he
turned that into being a vlogger now he
has he's is tremendously influential
essentially talk-show host which is
which is what he does via YouTube and
what I'll tell you how I first came in
contact with your work which was I was
having a conversation with a friend of
mine named Jason Harris who works at a
company called mechanism they do a lot
of work with youtubers and he's a very
very smart guy and I was lamenting the
fact that I felt like ah
the ship had sailed on YouTube for me
and that it was it was not the best fit
because I couldn't find it was hard for
me to find popular youtubers who were
not appealing primarily to say like the
12 to 15 year old demographic with like
super fast cuts and with a very very
particular style and I was pointed to
your work because a number of folks
including Jason said it was very smart
and probably hit a similar demographic
not so that I could copy it but so I
could look at it as a potential role
model so for for for someone let's say
in my shoes where I'm comfortable with
text I'm comfortable with audio haven't
done as much video although I've dabbled
in television I I am fascinated by the
allure and promise and direct connection
that YouTube offers how would you
suggest someone like me get started on
YouTube would it be with a daily vlog
would it be with something else how
should I kind of get my feet wet and and
start getting enthusiastic about it you
know I often get asked about what is the
best way to achieve success on YouTube
and the truth is if there were any one
defined path if there were anything that
was sort of quantifiable or anything
that could be written out I think a lot
of people would follow that trajectory
the reality is pretty far from that
though there are I don't know the exact
numbers but he needs 1.1 billion
different channels on YouTube and there
are 400 hours of content uploaded every
minute of every day to YouTube so like
the vast
the depth that is the ocean of YouTube
is is this huge abyss that's very hard
to stand out and the only thing that I
can say the only advice I ever give is
is don't think consideration will not
yield success on YouTube I think it
securely based around action some other
things that I push for is like quantity
matters it's not just the quality of the
work but it's also the quantity of the
work people look to YouTube not to find
great well-made films they look there
for relationships I think that's why
yeah I think that's why when you look at
like I don't know who can I pick on look
at Vanity Fair Vanity Fair is turning
out this incredibly high production
star-studded content nobody's watching
it nobody gives a [ __ ] that's not why
people watch YouTube there's no
relationship there the reason why I'm
psyched to be considered and identified
as a youtuber versus a filmmakers is
YouTube unlike filmmaking is not a
one-way street it's this reciprocal
symbiotic relationship that that your
content has with with a very specific
audience and then that that audience has
with your content so to succeed within
there is is very challenging and I think
the only way to do it is to find your
own path the only way to find that path
is to act is to start going and what
what let me dig into that because I I
like this thread and I'll just draw a
parallel in writing so I remember at one
point I was talking to PO Bronson a
writer I admire and I asked him what he
does when he feels blocked and he said
write about what you're right about what
angers you like write about what makes
you upset and that was very interesting
advice but that was a very prove to be
very helpful and has been helpful for me
when I feel like I'm having trouble
getting started
do you have any suggestions I'm happy to
act and I think a lot of people
listening would be as well but how do
they what might be some angles or
questions or ways they can get started
forget about success just to start
getting content out there um sure well I
think that what YouTube uniquely
possesses in its audience over any other
any other distribution outlet is that
the audience is so fine-tuned to
[ __ ] there [ __ ] detectors are so
highly refined that even the slightest
amount of [ __ ] will set off their
alarm and then you'll be rejected the
audience the community will reject you
immediately so a great place to start is
one of honesty one of frankness and that
sounds like hyperbolic or wishy-washy
but the truth is being yourself on
camera is an incredibly difficult thing
to do it's why the David Letterman's and
the Jimmy Fallon's of the world are so
brilliant is because when you're
watching Jimmy Kimmel on TV you really
believe that that's who this guy is
and when you see someone who is
uncomfortable in front of the camera
which is the vast majority of us it
reeks of something else which maybe is
something that's contrived or something
that's forced or something that's 8 so I
always say start from a place of honesty
and that's where the quantity comes into
play is because the more you're doing
something the more comfortable you
become with it so I think the
combination of those two and if you
throw in a little bit of passion what
truly motivates you what are you truly
interested in I think you can find it
really a an actionable recipe for
starting or building a foundation on
YouTube so it's it seems like uh correct
me if I'm wrong but that you putting out
one video per day that decision has made
your popularity really explode so I'd be
curious to know why you think that has
worked or why that has happened and then
a question from a fan that came up was
you said no to vlogging before because
you felt like it could make things feel
contrived how do you feel about this now
um well those are those are two
questions so let me
tackle tackle the first one which is
about popularity in YouTube the reason
why I started daily vlogging was because
I have to unpack this a little bit but
when I started my technology company
which is the social product which is
it's a social network I always knew that
I would need to lean on my own social
reach of my own influence to build a
core use a core base of users for my
product and then as I began and as my
tech company in the construction of it
really began my social reach started to
atrophy because I wasn't creating
content because I had run a company
someone really trying to examine how can
i address both of these issues which is
promote my own social influence so it
will help my company I just made a
decision on my birthday this year my
34th birthday that I'm going to start
daily vlogging um and coincidentally I
was like on this beautiful lovely trip
with my family and an exciting location
in the Caribbean and um and I had a lot
of material those first four days and a
lot of beautiful material to show off
and that's what I did and when I got
home the fourth lot of the fifth blog
ever made was like me returning to work
and I say into the camera like I don't
know how sustainable this is because I
live a fairly ordinary life where I show
up at work at at 8:00 or 9:00 in the
morning I leave work at 7:00 at night I
go home to my family and I go to bed
there's not much in there that warrants
vlogging every single day um and the
reason why I bring that specific up Tim
is because that dovetails with your next
question which is I used to reject
vlogging because it was a little bit of
is the dog wagging the tail or is the
tail wagging the dog in that I don't
want to be living my life so it's
interesting for my vlog right and the
reason why I those two points dovetail
so nicely is because when I said that on
the vlog when I said I don't know how to
make this interesting now that I'm back
at my daily life I understood vlogging
as a a visual public diary of one's life
and I think that's where I was wrong and
what this thing that I call a vlog and I
embrace that title that it's a blog
what it's become is instead of a daily
show for me and that show sometimes like
like the vlog I posted yesterday for
example is very much so a diary is my
wife and I and my daughter going on this
crazy trip out to Queens to try to buy
some funny clothes for a wedding that
we're going to in a few months it was
very much so a diary but then you look
at some of my other vlogs which was just
me sitting in front of a camera talking
to talking to my audience about why I'm
so passionate about filmmaking or
something much more personal and it
feels instead of a vlog it feels much
more like a confessional and some of my
vlogs are examining technical things
like my create my electric skateboard
I've got entire vlogs dedicated to how
this thing works and some of them are
out building things and some of them are
about how I structure my daily life so
really I just post every 24 hours and I
call it a vlog because that's the
easiest thing for me to call it that the
people understand but the truth is it's
it's not a diary of my life instead it's
this it's this outlet for whatever it is
that interests me so I hope that answers
the question from the fan it's that I
understand when I said that comment
about vlogging I understood blogging to
be one thing and then in practice and
this is where this is this really
reinforces that idea that I said about
action is so important in practice it
really manifested as something wildly
different what I literally understood it
to be and in your in your daily practice
your daily routine
I've read and that you might take say up
to 8 hours to edit one of your videos I
don't know if that's true we can get a
comment on that but how much time do you
spend interacting with fans or viewers
on YouTube Twitter all these different
social platforms on an average daily
basis what would you say I mean in
aggregate I would say it's less than
less than an hour I try my best but it's
very hard
usually I check into my my daily upload
about an hour after it's been posted I
see who who's commenting and what
they're saying and I jump in and try to
reply to as many as I possibly can on
Twitter you know you're pretty great on
Twitter Tim I've been following you
forever but you know you respond when
you can yeah I've got a minute of
downtime no one's looking you're sitting
in a car you're waiting for something
you just jump on Twitter and you reply
to a few tweets but I would say there's
nothing more defined than that for me
and I'd love to change that I'd love to
figure out a way to have it be much more
inclusive of my audience but regrettably
time is fungible and to dedicate more
time than I do currently to my audience
would need to take it away from
somewhere else I'm just not in a
position to do that what and I do the
same thing by the way I mean when I post
a blog post typically I'll post at night
so I can catch any errors that fans will
point out immediately so I'll try to hit
say the UK or New Zealand and then
answer questions the following morning
or along those lines and it's something
that you just have to batch but what was
your first paid gig related to film or
when did you realize that you could
actually give this again as a profession
awesome question um the first day gig
ever had was I to make a happy birthday
video for this guy named Tom Tom's
husband was getting was he's turning 50
years old and Tom contacted my brother
and I and he said hey I've seen some of
your little art movies in the art world
floating around the art world this is
like 2001 2002 rather and he was like
I'd love to hire you to make a movie for
my husband ah and for my husband's
birthday and we're like okay great he
was like just let me know what it costs
and all I knew at the time was that he
was like a rich guy so like we debated
for days like what do we charge this guy
and we came back with what we saw was
the most like ambitious number we could
possibly go to him with which is like we
asked for five thousand dollars and the
truth is we were willing and ready to do
it for $100 we knew he was a rich guy
and we knew that he liked us and we knew
that he'd bought really fancy art so
maybe just maybe we did
with it he didn't die neither he's a no
problem and then he said here are a list
of people I'd love for you to interview
about my husband and it was like
President Clinton waddle like senator
Hillary Clinton all the members of their
cabinet like all of these triple a rock
star politicians and we were just like
holy smokes who is this guy it was it
was a Fred Hochberg who is currently the
chairman of the import-export Bank and
his husband is a guy named Tom Healy and
Tom is currently the chairman of the
Fulbright Commission so there are two
probably the biggest power couple one of
the biggest power couples out there and
there are two lovely guys who to this
day I'm very very close friends with and
we got our 5,000 bucks for that gig and
it was it was a huge deal that's amazing
did they just email you through the
contact email on your website or how did
that connection happen well there's no
website back then um back then back then
I was working for $10 an hour as like an
artists assistant and in the interim I
was making my brother of Ann and I were
making these little movies in my
apartment that we would post on
literally like Apple I disk and we email
around the links so people could
download the dot MOV files and watch
them and somehow one of the artists we
knew or something like that was like I
gotta check out these two young maniacs
that I've met who make these crazy
little videos and he saw it he was like
I don't want a boring video for
Freddie's birthday I want something that
like he's gonna keep people laughing and
he gave us this crazy this he gave us
this assignment we came back with
something absolutely crazy that involved
like that involved you know when we met
with Hillary
sorry MacDill Clinton they had a
prepared statement on his teleprompter
haha and when the Secret Service left
the room to go get the president I
deleted all the information off the
teleprompter and then while the
president is sitting there in his seat
waiting for the teleprompter I just
remember him being like Nancy what's
going on here I rushed over to him with
my hands down so I didn't get tackled by
security and I was like hello mr.
president my name is Casey I'm here to
do this interview for you for Fred
Hochberg
here's an idea I had and he started
laughing he was like boys I love it and
we hit record and we had the Nugget
recorded before they got to tell her
promptings out of the room and when he
said the joke that we had him say in
front of the 500 people Atlas circ where
we showed the movie for Fred's birthday
it brought down the house that that's a
ballsy move but I mean I shouldn't be
surprised you're pretty ballsy bulb guy
to start with I mean back then it was
like definitely had nothing to lose kind
of situation right I was he we were
absolutely nobody's getting paid ten
dollars an hour for I couldn't afford
food back then that's not that's not
that's not hyperbole that is fact
what now what when you uh well let me
let me take a step back wit when you
think of the word successful who is the
first person who comes to mind and why
that's a tough question my grandmother a
grandma is probably the most successful
she passed away to your three years four
years dhadak it's not picking back she
passed away at age 92 and she is like
she's my hero she's my muse she's my
everything and the reason why is she
started tap dancing when she was six
years old she's a little fat girl and
her parents made her do something to
lose lose the weight so she started tap
dancing and she loved it and she fell in
love with something at age six and if he
didn't stop tap dancing until the day
before she died at age 92 she died on a
Monday morning at age 92 and the first
thing we had to do after she died was
call her 100 students to say she wasn't
going to make class that day Wow um and
for me it's just like I mean she's never
rich uh she actually never had a whole
lot of money she's a tap dance
instructor but she dedicated all the
proceeds from her tap recitals to the
American Cancer Society to raise money
to beat cancer because cancer took her
father so she's she's a total hero and a
philanthropist despite not having the
means and then on top of that is just
like what what is the ultimate
quantification of success for me it's
not how much time you spend doing what
you love it's how much time you spend or
how little time you spend doing what you
hate and this woman spent all day every
day doing what she loved all day she
spent almost
no time doing the thing she didn't want
to do um she just did what she loved the
most in life which was dancing and she
did that was dancing was her life you'd
wake up in the morning she was dancing
go to bed at night she's watching Fred
Astaire on TV and that was her you know
that was 86 years of her 92 years of
existence she spent doing nothing but
exactly what she loved and I just can't
think of a higher benchmark of success
than that how has that impacted you on a
daily basis and I'll just I'll rephrase
that when you wake up in the morning and
you don't feel like putting out the
video right do you have those days and
if so what do you do in those
circumstances what do you say to
yourself well I always want to put out
the video I don't always want to make
the video so to like give a little
structure to that my day looks like is I
wake up at 4:30 in the morning is when
my alarm goes off this is 7 days a week
and I edit I finished my edit from the
night before the Edit gets done and
usually between 6:30 and 7:00 from 7:00
to 7:45 it's processing uploading the
designing in color correcting everything
the thumbnail that goes on YouTube
preparing the post so it's up it's live
it's rendered it's fully processed and
it goes live at exactly 8:00 a.m. that's
seven days a week
immediately after 8:00 a.m. I I work out
which usually involves running you know
whatever I run eight to twelve miles or
going to the gym and then I'm in my
office like 9:30 ish I live across the
street from my for my office so it's a
pretty narrow commute and then I work in
my office all day long I usually try to
get out of here by 6:30 race home give
the baby a bath
and then hanging out with my wife for an
hour and a half she goes to bed at like
9:00 and then I sit down and I edit
until I pass out of my computer till
1:00 in the morning I sleep usually on
the couch until 4:30 which is like you
know three four hours later I wake up
and I start over and that is seven days
a week for me um sometimes on the
weekend I spent a less time in the
office but that's everyday that's a
brutal uh it's tough so
have you always needed very little sleep
yeah I've always I've never ever been a
fan of sleep I hate sleep sleeping
eating or like my two least favorite
things to do and I'm frustrated every
day when I get tired and I'm frustrated
when I get hungry haha I can help you
with the latter
maybe not the tired but the been doing
all sorts of fasting experiments what
time do you eat breakfast and what do
you eat for breakfast I mean I usually
don't uh I only like I said honey nut
cheerios when you asked me earlier
during our audio during the soundcheck
right because whichever I have no idea
who but some one of our team members of
our tech company is a big fan of them
there's always honey nut cheerios in
milk in my in my my office so when I
hear somebody else spoon clanking a
porcelain on the glue Cheerios and I get
up but just cuz that's sugar and that's
delicious um but no I don't I don't know
that I am a big breakfast eater
I usually just wait til I get really
hungry and then I eat until the hunger
stops and and then I repeat that seems
seems like the most natural way to go
back as opposed to eating at the by the
clock you know I just have to mention
honey that sure his I had a breakfast
with Larry King for the first time not
long ago and we met at a sort of a
Jewish bagel shop and he goes there
every morning and then eats honey nut
cheerios so they have to keep it stocked
at this place for him I just thought
that was one of the most unusual things
I'd ever seen but seems like a number of
top performers eat honey nut cheerios
for breakfast so maybe there's something
there when not speaking of Larry King
I've always kind of idolized him for his
ability to get people to open up uh do
you have you've met so many people so
many successful people over the years in
different professions who has made you
feel starstruck and why
who has made me feel starstruck um god
that is a tricky one uh it's funny
because you know I go to like a lot of
big celebrity events and it never really
hits me with the kinds of people that
you would think that it would hit me
with um I'm trying to think like I met
Jack Welsh once in the street right and
for whatever reason starstruck by him I
was so excited to meet him um but
honestly I don't know I I really just
starstruck as something that that's an
experience I don't know super well and I
guess the reason why it's just like I
have about as much appreciation
understanding of that as I do when
people get excited to meet me and I say
that right now looking out the I have a
monitor in my office at camera films
just outside the sidewalk and I can
count 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 13 14 kids
standing outside of my office right now
ready waiting to see me
wow that's everyday it never stops
and I haven't got as much understanding
or ability to understand empathize with
those kids us at my office as I do get
the idea of getting starstruck um so why
Jamie why Jack Welch I have no idea I
maybe since I just finished one of his
books but um and I had all these ideas
in my head that he had planted there and
that's something flattering but no I I
don't I definitely see people as as
people at face value and I think that
you know what you contribute and what
you do is incredibly meaningful and
important but at the end of the day we
are all people and I think that it's
tough for me to try to elevate someone
else and in the same regard when I see
videos that autoplay on Facebook of
Syrian refugees getting beaten on the
Macedonian border by officers with clubs
I would say that I have or whatever
whatever that feeling of empathy would
be for a movie star I share that with
them when I look at these people I'm
like you know I see Kanye West and I'm
like okay he's a person just like me
I see someone holding a baby getting
beaten with a club while it's pouring
rain out I say that person's just like
me and it's very hard for me to think of
a human being as some as someone other
than than an equal right and I realized
I kind of walked over my own question or
probably walked over your answer to thee
when you feel demotivated or that you
don't want to make a video what do you
do it is it that the is it that your
regimented seven-day week schedule just
doesn't allow the space for that
self-doubt or oh no you know I didn't
answer the question either
I digress and something but ah no so
it's very real and waking up to edit I
never want to do it like yesterday I
just said it was Sunday morning I'm not
going to do it and I didn't I didn't get
my post up until 1:00 in the afternoon
there's a total mutiny on on on Twitter
by my viewers but uh I don't want to do
it but the truth is like I can only
equate it to climbing a mountain I've
climbed some really big mountains before
and when you're the closest to the peak
is when you want to give up the most but
the return that is standing at the
summit is such a victory that the minute
you're up there you just want to do it
again and you've forgotten about the
pain
so the hate that is the Battle of the
edit and the upload and the [ __ ] and
the getting it done the technical
problems that are outside of your
control and the camera not recording
audio and like every other hurdle that
that it comes between you and uploading
all of that is absolved all that is
erased the moment you click upload and
it's replaced with this like sensation
of adrenaline and wonderment and
achievement and accomplishment that is
having made something that I now get to
share and that was true when I was
making a birthday video that couple
hundred people in the room got to see
that was true when I was making videos
of my son when he was a baby and I'll
share them with my family and that's
certainly true of my daily uploads on
YouTube that go out to you know a
million people a day and you you seem to
be very contrarian on if you've always
been that way but you're also very
well-spoken so you dropped out of high
school how do you explain that how did
you sort of do
that ability um and it's not to say that
somebody drops out of high school can't
be well-spoken but it's it's it's uh I'm
very impressed with how well spoken you
are so I'd just be curious to know why
you think or how you develop that no no
I may be reading louder I was trying to
surround myself with people that are
smarter than than I am I mean I can
remember and when I when I got my first
real job when my at the time girlfriend
was pregnant with my first kid now
sixteen years old and I was in the back
of a kitchen and everybody just sort of
thought that I was an idiot probably
because of my age and the fact that I
was kind of a dope and I probably talk
like an idiot then as a tenth grade high
school dropout whose only previous work
experience was selling dime bags in the
parking lot of high school um the lack
of respect and what that felt like
and then I really remember you know
again sixteen years old and kitchen of a
really dumpy seafood restaurant getting
paid $8 an hour I really remember what
would happen when I acted differently
around these these guys that I worked in
the kitchen with how they would treat me
differently and every day became the
sort of social study for me the social
experiment were in how would they
respond to me acting a certain way and I
remember like when they would pick on me
instead of me trying to come up with
quippy comebacks to them I would just
look them in the eye and not say
anything and then the picking on me
stopped immediately and I guess like
that little experiment right there was
something that had a huge impact on me
because you know the more considered I
am when I say things more I think before
I speak and things like that I think the
more people respond in the way that I
hope people respond and the more I feel
like I'm doing a good job of
communicating whatever it is that I'm
trying to say whatever information that
isn't I'm trying to disseminate the more
satisfying it is for me it feels great
to be understood so I just I do whatever
I can that best services that as far as
the educational part or being out an
autodidact I'm the big fan of reading
I'm a big fan of World War two let me
say like I got all my business my
understanding of biz
a business and life works from studying
the Second World War at any particular
books or documentaries or resources on
world war ii that you're the your big
fan of oh yeah probably my favorite or
at least my second favorite book in the
world it's a textbook and it's called
the Second World War by John Keegan and
it's literally just like 1,200 pages
that size 6 thought about the second
world war and I remember like getting in
trouble filling up to work tired because
I would be up all night long reading
this textbook about world war 2 so
riveting to me I already covered a cover
probably three times ah I remember
reading the New York Times that John
Keeton passed away just you know late mm
maybe 2008-2009 time ago and being
deeply sad that this military lecturer
this professor from England had died
because I felt so close to him because I
read this book there was nothing more
than academics perspective on the second
world war was not a first-hand
experience there's no emotion in this
book it's pure military strategy and I
remember deeply being emotionally
affected by the fact that this guy had
died but that's one book in particular
that really affected me how are you
introduced to that book or how did you
find it I have no idea I mean I can tell
you actually I was at a dinner party
with a girl I had a crush on whose
mother was a columnist in the New York
Times and they were talking about World
War two and one of them said what year
did World War two start or something
like that and I remember thinking in my
head what year - world war two start and
I literally couldn't tell you forget
about the decade I couldn't tell you
what part of the century took place in
and I remember in that moment feeling
like an idiot the same way I felt like
an idiot in the kitchen when I got
picked on and the next day I just went
to Barnes and Nobles there's no Amazon
then and like found whatever looked like
the most down the line like straight
forward book on the Second World War so
I could make sure that the next time I
was in a conversation when World War 2
came out I'd be much more versed in it
amazing
and you said second favorite book what
is what is the other book that was in
your mind
um the autobiography of malcolm x i have
read that book more times than I can
count
I cried at the end of that book I don't
know why I guess I was surprised that
Malcolm X was killed even though he'd
been dead for 40 years and I knew that
he had been shot that book resonates me
in such a way you know he just like he
was a bad kid he was a troublemaker he's
arrested he's thrown in jail as a
dropout and a thug and I say this like
with some hesitation because that man is
an absolute hero who really changed the
world for for the better and for so many
people so I don't compare myself to him
in any capacity but certainly when I
read that book for the first time I saw
so many parallels between his struggles
again in a universal way and the
struggles that I had and he don't he was
a troublemaker he wasn't selling dime
bags he was doing real crime with guns
and robbing people and he went to jail
and you know he taught himself educated
himself while in prison to the degree he
developed an astigmatism in his eye from
reading Wow
in like the super dim prison light and
he went into prison the you know the
degenerate thug that he was and he came
out of prison I think one of the
greatest communicators of the 20th
century in someone who's whose ideas and
the profundity behind the way he was
able to share those ideas affected the
world and affected the civil rights
movement in such a way that we still
feel the impact of it today he's just
such a hero and that book is written so
in such a brilliant way that's so
relatable even today that I can't think
of another piece of writing that's
impacted me the way that movie that book
has won was he sucked not that much not
the movie the book what what book have
you gifted most to other people is it
one of these two ORS or no the book that
gifted the most people that there's a
real trouble with gifting books which is
that II if you're gifting someone a book
it means you think that they're going to
actually read it and I would say more
often than not most books that are
gifted say more are more gesture by the
person who gifted them to you than they
are
are you receiving them like most people
gift the kind of books that I received
they just want to feel special and be
able to say I gave you that book that's
a little cynicism for you but no the
book I've gifted the most is a book
called it's not how good you are it's
how good you want to be I think that's
the name of the book I mean look it up
right now but what it is it's written by
an adman and it's about Sir the art of
advertising it's a great title I mean uh
even if it's not the right title I like
the sound of it the reason why I get
that book is because you can read it in
like 40 minutes right each page is like
20 words on it and each one of them
captures like these really big lofty
ideas there it is it's not how good it's
how good you want to be by Paul Arden
and each book has like few hundred and
fifty font text which says one sentence
but each one like really punches you in
the stomach in a really big way um and I
think it this book has the ability and
it was written by an ad man but I think
it's really it's just about creativity
in general how to break through in a way
that really affects you I think that
there's a passage in there where he
talks about how when hiring and when
being when hiring always see someone
who's been fired or who has quit their
previous job as a virtue
and like it's a bunch of little items
like that and I don't I just think it's
a magnificent book that you can sit down
and we'll shake anybody up who reads it
I'll check it out I'm in the shake up
phase at the moment uh he can ask just a
couple of rapid-fire questions they
don't need to be rapid-fire our answers
but I'll throw just a bunch of questions
at you what $100 or less purchase has
most positively impacted your life in
the last six to twelve months or
whatever comes to mind
$100 or less purchase that's a really
really challenging answer a question to
answer um where's hi I'm not extremely
expensive no I understand yeah um so
it's not that reason but it is something
that I say to young people want to get
into filmmaking but the movie that I
shot the camera that I
got the bike lanes movie on cost one
hundred and fifty dollars and you
started this interview out by by asking
about that movie and I think that speaks
to just how impactful that movie was and
that movie was shot a hundred and fifty
dollar camera from Walmart and that
movie was edited in iMovie which is free
software so I think that when I look
back at like words really big impact
spin when it comes to making a little
investment that that movie and that that
hundred fifty dollar investment the
impact that I had in my life and my
career is something that I often point
to as like don't blame it on the gear
don't blame it on a lack of resources
because it's never the resources that
determine your success it's it's how you
use what you have and is there any entry
level camera that you might suggest to
people now who are looking for an
equivalent and just getting started or
is the phone good enough I mean I think
the phones that are great they're way
better than good enough but if you look
at a lot of the big vloggers like
vlogging was was a was invented by
people just using the webcams and their
computers so I really just don't think
the quality matters I think cellphones
now are incredible if you want to get
something bigger than that you go to the
store and you buy whatever the whatever
the cheapest Canon point-and-shoot
cameras it all has a high def video
record button they get stereo sound
they've got zoom it's more than what you
need to tell a great story it's never
the hardware it's only how you use it
and speaking of vloggers so I'm not
familiar with the world of lagers
outside of your own who are a few
vloggers maybe they have different
styles that people could check out just
to get a feel for how people are going
about doing this sure and so there's one
guy who's a good friend of mine a name's
Ben Brown spell as you'd imagine
and Ben is uh Ben's a guy who he's a
really honest Frank guy and I think what
Ben doesn't vlogging he's a daily
vlogger that's so his vlogs are very
much so by definition just a diary of
his life um but I think what Ben does
better than anyone is he really is
himself on camera so what you're seeing
on camera is who he is in real life and
what the impact of that is in aggregate
is that after you spend day in and day
out watching a ten-minute vlogs
every day is he becomes a friend he
becomes a friend by proxy and he lives a
somewhat adventurous life he's got a
beautiful girlfriend and kid Town South
Africa where he spends the majority of
his time even though he's from England
and he travels a lot for work
his work is logging so you sort of you
span this guy's life along with him and
via that you you feel like you become
friends with him so I think he really
captures what is the the romanticism
behind vlogging behind sharing your life
in a in a daily capacity via video got
it any anyone else come to mind just so
people can look at a few different
options sure there's a guy named fun for
Louis fun a few nfor fun for ello you I
asked Louie Louie is is very similar to
Ben Louie is like a godfather of
vlogging and doing it like for years
he's someone who is like six foot
forward long dreadlocks and just
rejected the grind and he wanted to live
a life of adventure and he literally is
traveling 365 days a year
any bankrolls at all by sharing those
experiences that he he does via his
camera and be a youtube he doesn't drink
he doesn't do drugs he doesn't have a
girlfriend
he's just an honest guy on sort of a
journey to to define himself and I find
his vlogs to be very humble and honest
and that they capture who he is and he
shares that in a way that I think is
extremely relatable what what are the
most common misconceptions about you or
your work would you say god that's tough
and it's tough only because I paid
little attention to the two negative
people and the people that are wasting
their time criticizing what would they
call that about Steve Jobs is like
really distortion videos yeah so what
the biggest misconceptions um you know
people think I'm really rich and I think
that's a kind of a frustrating
misconception and the reason why it's
frustrating isn't because I don't have a
wonderful absolutely privileged life
which I do it's frustrating because of
how many times in life I've said no
huge paychecks because they didn't align
with who I am as a person you know I
said no to $100,000 job today on YouTube
because of what they wanted me to do and
what they wanted me to say I just passed
on it and that's been the case from when
I was really really broke if it wasn't
something that I thought I could get
behind that I believed in I just said no
and I think that if if money were my
focus I would have found a home in
advertising done very well there and
never looked back
but instead I've always stayed true to
what really matters to me
this sharing ideas and sharing
perspectives and I've done that with
tremendous financial risk that that has
cost me probably prevented me from being
this rich got it that people think that
I am how how do you decide what to say
no to so for instance if you're
comfortable talking about it and I ask
because I'm constantly trying to get
better at saying no and you mentioned
Steve Jobs and he was he's famously
quoted for a lot of things but one of
them was you know innovation is saying
no to a thousand things or being
successful saying no to a thousand
things instead of always striving for
that simplicity what did the company
what made you uncomfortable that led to
the no or you could speak more generally
if you want to but I'm trying to get
better at this myself and I'm always
looking for play books or rules that
other people use uh I was terrified
absolutely terrified to say no for so
long and it's because it was such a
novel idea this this idea that someone
was going to pay me to pick up a camera
something that I had not just done for
free but something that I had like spent
every every last cent of my life to be
able to do and now people were willing
to pay me and then willing to pay me a
shitload of money and then I had to say
no so something that was really scary
for me to do um but I would say that
transition happened a couple of years
ago and the more I said no the more it
made me feel better and III don't know
what the signs to it is but I can tell
you that when I launched not on launch
but when I got the first little bit of
financing for my technology company and
went for being an idea to something more
tangible I just immediately said no to
every
and that's pretty much where I lie right
now is everything is given one filter
and that one filter is is this good for
me and my tech company and if the answer
is no it's a it's a pass and if the
answer is a yes it gets an examination
and and I definitely want to talk about
beam for people who also want to develop
this ability to say no there's a
commencement speech by a neil gaiman
called make good art which I just find
fantastic but he has some really good
metaphors for this as well and I'm going
to come back to beam in just a second
but what what do you believe that other
people think is insane what is a belief
that you have that other people think
many people think is crazy ah it's funny
because to the listeners out there I'm
talking to you right now not Tim but Tim
sent me all these questions saying if
you want to rehearse for this so you
have the answers and I came back with an
emphatic I don't like to know the
questions ahead of time because then
they're rehearsed and now I'm finding
myself with these really challenging
questions or asting I'm grasping to come
up with a an answer that's true um
okay what do I believe that that's crazy
um or that other people think is crazy
but you might not and this is it this is
a common interview question and this is
a paraphrase that Peter Thiel co-founder
or former CEO of PayPal and first money
into Facebook that he uses a lot so this
is something you believe that's
controversial or that other people think
is nuts
yeah I think I think they talked about
this in the first chapter of zero to one
um yeah I'm sure comes up I'm sure comes
up uh
I you know I believe in the religion of
work and working hard and I think that I
think that that's something that people
resist people resist the notion of and
the more I find myself sort of preaching
the values and the virtues of that the
more resistant people are but I just
believe that anything can be achieved
through hard work and it's hard it's
hard to say as I as I'm hearing myself
say that it sounds like something that
you know some some [ __ ] guy who's
down six
we'll say but I really like the truth is
the harder I work is the harder I work
the more successful I am and moreover
you realize that like you will never
you'll never be the best looking person
in the room you'll never be the smartest
person in the room you'll never be the
most educated the best well versatile
you'll never be you can never compete on
those levels you'll never be the most
educational evel's but you can always
compete on the true like egalitarian
aspect to success is hard work you can
always work harder than the next guy and
if you're willing to work harder than
the next guy you will succeed because
most people like I always say when when
someone's like yeah but I'm not going to
dedicate I'm not going to commit to
working like I'm not waking up I'm not
how did you sleep a couple I'm not going
to do I'm not the second I hear someone
say that I think to myself great that is
one less person I have to climb over on
my way to the top because I I know what
hard work can yield and I know just how
just how meaningful hard work can be
mm-hmm there's uh one of my it's a I
don't know why I'm so embarrassed to
admit this but one of my favorite semi
sort of documentary but it's more of a
historical reenactment film that I've
seen is called miracle and it's a Disney
movie with Kurt Russell about this this
incredible story of the u.s. hockey team
and the Olympics at Lake Placid going
against the the Soviets who are
considered unbeatable but in one of the
training sessions he says you know
they're just bickering amongst
themselves and and and looking at hot
chicks in the stands instead of taking
the game seriously and he's like oh well
I know you guys think you have a lot of
talent but talent you don't have enough
talent to make it in this particular
game but I can promise you that will
outwork every other team that's going to
play us in the Olympics so yeah I do
think there's a lot a lot to pull from
that the tech company so tell me a
little tell me and the the listeners
about beam but related to that I mean
you have a you have an amazing life
you've you've created an amazing life
for yourself through
and hard work have been a popular
director you have sundance HBO etc you
can make a lot of money some youtubers
I'm not going to say you but youtubers
can make you know five six figures for
product placement on YouTube so why on
earth start a tech company and and then
what did what is the tech company ah you
know it's it's it was at the height it
was at the the peak of my career that I
actually pivoted to starting this tech
company and the peak of that career is
one of doing branded content deals on my
YouTube channel and yeah those deals
were six figures and and seven-figure
deal so huge huge huge deals and in
starting my company my technology come
actually shut down my production company
that was doing those tremendous deals so
part of that rejection around me being
rich is because of that is because I
shut down I killed the I killed the the
Golden Goose yeah I killed
I killed the cow that was there I had
been milking for years to do this
because that's how much I believe in
this but what started the tech company
was this I was I was doing advertising
work for YouTube for my YouTube channel
and it was fantastically successful I
was tremendously proud of it all of that
but I really felt like I'd exhausted it
I had reached a plateau where people I
was doing similar work and even though
was good and people loved it I didn't
feel like it was moving me forward in
any way and it was around that time that
I was invited to uh to MIT to
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
and I was invited there via the Sundance
Institute and a grant from the
Rockefeller Foundation and they invited
me to live on campus and work out of the
Media Lab for six months and I remember
thinking about that my initial gut
response was like that leave my company
for six months how much is that going to
possibly cost me like I can't afford to
do that's crazy say no to all this money
I've never said no to anything in my
life and the more I thought about the
more I was like you know what I can
probably afford to do this I can
probably afford to live off my savings
for six months I'll be dead broke at the
end of it but this is an opportunity
unlike anything else and I just didn't
said bucket and I went for it and I
lived on campus and I never went to
college never went to high school never
went to college and I just went there
with a wide open mind I had wanted janda
and that agenda was when I leave here I
want to make sure I have an
understanding I'm doing something that
I've I've never done before I'm doing
something that is not currently on the
books because I don't get it and while
at MIT I learned one thing one very
meaningful one very powerful thing that
one thing was that with technology
almost anything is achievable and
therefore I took that understanding when
I came back to New York after my my
tenure there was over after my semester
there was over my fellowship was
complete I came back to New York and I
came back to New York and I wanted to
solve a problem I wanted to solve a
problem that I identified years ago but
I didn't think was solvable and I wanted
to take this new understanding that I
could solve big problems with technology
and I wanted to realize that and that
was the prelude to me starting a
technology company and and can you
explain the the premise of beam tell
people where they can check it out but
also the how it works I mean the basic
the basic conceit behind it yeah sure so
that problem that problem that I really
wanted to solve was one that my life has
been so impacted in such a meaningful
way by my ability to share my ideas in
my perspective but I have a unique
unfair competitive advantage when it
comes to sharing ideas and perspectives
which is that I know how to make movies
I have this creative expression so I can
share my perspective because of that
Larry King I had a CNN talk show he
fares perspective because of that and is
there a way to with technology make it
so you can actually share perspectives
and share ideas without having to create
something can you bifurcate this idea of
creation from this idea of sharing and
that was a problem that I wanted to
solve and to unpack that a little bit
even something like a YouTube it first
requires you to make a video and then
you have to upload a video there's an
active
creation in there when you think of
something like Instagram like de litter
you have to come up with that clever
tweet snapchat you have to shoot
something you review it you added it you
see what it looks like you had some
filters to it you draw on the screen and
then you get to share what would it look
like if you remove the entire process
all the mechanics of creation and that's
what beam is that's how beam work so
literally how beam works and it's be eme
beam
how it works is you cover the proximity
sensor on your on your cell phone and
the proximity sensor is this tiny black
dot that's right above the speaker hole
at the top of your phone and when you
cover that sensor it automatically
starts recording a video clip and the
minute that clip is done which is four
seconds later it's immediately posted to
your feet so what that looks like in
practice is when you see something of
interest when there's something you want
to share an idea perspective
I don't know so a cute puppy anything
you want to share you just hold your
phone to your chest or you put your
thumb over the proximity sensor the
screen goes black it captures it
vibrates when it's done and then you put
the phone back in your pocket you just
shared something using the most media
rich content that's ever existed which
is in which is video it's sound and
you've done it without ever having to
create not ever having to take in front
that burden that is a creative
expression very cool yeah I've been
watching it with with great interest and
playing around with it so I encourage
people to check it out I know we are
coming up on time for both of us so I
want to just ask a couple more questions
and then absolutely going to ask you to
share where people can can check out a
number of things related to your work
what are some underrated the most
underrated documentaries or movies in
your mind just if they could just be a
few films that people might check out
that perhaps they haven't come across
because they haven't been fully
appreciated okay so my favorite movie is
is probably the life and death of
Colonel blimp which is a movie it's a
British movie that was made that was
made during World War two and it's my
favorite movie period it's a movie that
Wes Anderson really studied and you can
see a lot of his style in that movie for
example like the opening title sequence
all of the credit
are embroidered into a gigantic blanket
and the shots are just of that blank and
this amou v that was made in the in
their 1948 in 1941 and that movie to me
is like that's my favorite movie cuz he
captures everything I love about
filmmaking but it also had to be made at
a time when like the country this
priority was saving themselves from
destruction and death and instead you
know like that's the priority and
instead like at that same time they
decided to make a movie and like that is
such a novel such a wild idea and they
had no resources when they needed big
wide establishing shots I just filmed a
painting because I couldn't fly a
balloon or an airplane to take the shot
because it was it was during the war so
that's my favorite movie other movies
like my favorite Doc is probably if they
were documentary is probably little
dieter needs to fly which is a movie
from from Verner Herzog from 1997 he's
gone dieter di edr I guess di t Oh er
and little little dieter needs to fly is
about a it's about a Vietnam a u.s.
Vietnam fighter pilot gets shot down his
very first mission and he's trapped as a
POWs for a number of years and the
movies actually made as a fictional
narrative or non fictional narrative
called rescue Don with Christian Bale a
couple years ago but skip the
description bill and just watch the
documentary that movie will bring you to
your knees and it shows you like that's
one of those movies at any time you're
having a bad day or you think you've got
it hard you watch that movie and you
understand what it means to like to
survive um you know it's a story of a
guy who ate eight maggots for four years
and finally escaped and the best friend
killed and you know much of the
interviews that were done with him when
he was living at the in Portland Oregon
or something like that and they Peter
takes you into his basement underground
he has like hundreds of pounds of sugar
and flour and oats in the u.s. in the
90s because he's so scared of being
hungry
again that he wanted to make sure no
matter what he'll never be hungry again
for the rest of his life and it's just
like he captured humanity in such a
visceral such a
real way and it's a work of nonfiction
so it's really that's a movie that that
that's that's that's moved me sounds
like a great perspective adjuster uh if
you could have one billboard anywhere
what would you put on it and where would
you put it
ah God I don't I don't know I mean it
probably I'd want to I'd love to have a
billboard someone that just reminds
people to be nice where I put it is
wherever the most people would possibly
see it but I think it we I don't know
that communication actually I do I think
that communication social networks the
Internet has made this better it's it's
going the right direction I think people
are so quick to be judgmental and be
negative and the truth is like if you
give other people the benefit of the
doubt and you you have a positive
approach to everything in life that you
end up being happier and it's better for
them it's like that that absolutely
quantifiable mathematical equation which
is that if what's best for you and me is
better for me than just what's better
for me does that make sense I'll say it
again yeah sorry that benefits Tim and
Casey is that in it for Casey than just
something that benefits Casey and I
think positivity and being nice is a big
part of that it's something that's often
overlooked the grid what what advice
would you give your 20 year old self
20 year old yeah or 2 or 25 whichever
you I mean I would say about 15 year old
self but yeah you can answer that one it
would be don't listen to anyone don't
listen to anyone
I I have a rule which is always listened
to everyone and then reject everything
you don't like but the truth is like so
many people love sharing knowledge and
it has such an impact on people and
affects them in such a way and the truth
is no one knows anything and life is
this malleable mushy piece of play
that's only up to you to shape and you
look to much to other people to help you
shape that piece of clay that is your
life you end up with it with a
compromised life
stocks is something that's not your own
how do you end up feeling overwhelmed by
the paradox of choice in a situation
like that if you adopt that philosophy
and I'm not diving I tend to agree a lot
of the time but I also at points feel
like I have too much optionality and it
makes it very difficult to navigate
there's a lot of self-doubt maybe that's
just my own neuroses that need
addressing but how do you how do you
find direction in all of those options
and all that freedom you know I
that's a really awesome that's a billion
dollar question and I think if you could
answer that I don't have an answer for
that I can tell you that I can tell you
that my wife is someone who and actually
would agree with me if here didn't say
this but she's just someone who's
crippled by indecision
she showed me choice in front of her and
her lack of ability just to zero and one
it's it's it affects her in a
tremendously negative way and I tend to
be very George Bush the second George
Bush about this I'm not a tremendous fan
of George Bush at all but that man made
mostly bad decisions but he made
decisions and I really believe I need to
come up with a better person what I but
I really believe like you make a
decision and you move on that decision
and it's better to later in life figure
out that that was the wrong decision
than it is to sit around and have never
had made a decision in the first place
and that's a really scary thing to do
but the truth is like I'm only 35 years
old but I'm also 35 years old I would
whatever it is 20 years in it as an
adult now which is just about enough
time to look back and start to examine
examine things and I think that having
always opted to trust my instinct
because my instincts are there to keep
me alive to trust my instincts and to
move on them has only benefited me
despite myriad failures along the way
yeah I can I can see how the World War 2
reading probably Civ influenced still
without what I agree with is the ability
to make decisions with incomplete
information a very good very good advice
last question before we wrap up
do you have any ask or requests for my
audience anything that you would ask
them to do or suggest that they do uh no
I mean it's it's it's wonderful having
an audience to speak to and something
that I always try to tell anyone that
will listen even though I just chartered
a to myself by saying never listen to
anyone but it's just that idea of being
nice when you share positivity out there
that he comes back in such a big way and
that's such a lame like TV evangelist
thing to say but the truth is like that
is so meaningful it is so cheap it is so
inexpensive it is so easy to be cynical
to be negative to be someone who brings
other people down and brings yourself
down is really easy to do being nice
being positive is really hard work but
you feel so much better at the end of
the day it's just like exercise you
don't want to get out there and do your
run you don't want to go to the gym but
when you do you feel so much better so
much glad you're so much better off that
you did it and at the end of the day at
the end of life at the end of the year
the aggregate of having done that having
put in the work to be a more positive
person that's really tremendous and I
you know their two kids now so I set all
this in their shadows and the older I
get the more I really believe in that
and I work hard to achieve that every
minute of every day what do you have
people have asked me this so I'm going
to ask you what what do you what have
you been listening to most when you run
recently I mean the problem with me is
I'm not much with music I'm not much of
a moralist and it comes to music I hate
that answer I love everything but I love
everything um an old friend of mine his
name is Johnny Johnny famous is his name
on on Spotify and that's no age Jo and
then why famous Johnny famous I just
listened his playlist he's like this
incredible DJ was DJ parties with me all
kinds of fun stuff but I just go to him
and I'm like Johnny what are you
listening to and Spotify enables that
and I just listened his playlist so
that's not a super sexy answer but it's
the truth
no it's specific it's perfect alright I
this has been so much fun
I know we've we've tried to connect over
the past weeks and months and
it's it's finally here in front of us
where can people find you on the
internet where can they check out you
and your work and maybe maybe give them
a video or two to start with also um
yeah I mean everything I've ever done is
on YouTube just type my name into Google
you'll find it if I have to say start
somewhere watch that movie make it count
because we spend so much time talking
about it and then another movie that I'd
like to point to is a movie I worked
really hard on that
is kind of under under watching on
YouTube but it's it's called draw my
life and basically it's it is like my
autobiography that I made via little
drawings that a friend of mine did and
it's something I worked super hard on
it's like a 12-minute summation of
everything I've done from birth until
age 30 or so and it's something I'm
really really proud of that little movie
and then your your audience to download
beam be Emmy it's on the App Store now
we'll have it on android probably in
November or working really hard to get
it there but beam is a really really
exciting really it's a burgeoning
community that's growing every day
and I don't know it's the more people
that are part of being more exciting it
becomes so awesome well Casey thank you
so much for taking the time and
everybody listening for show notes links
to everything that we mentioned in this
conversation you can just go to four
hour work week com all spelled out and
click on podcasts that also has all past
episodes and Casey this is great
hopefully we can hang out when we're in
the same city and best of luck with
everything
thanks for taking the time of course
this is in fantastic take care ten
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday the vet provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by Vimeo
Pro which is the ideal video hosting
platform for entrepreneurs and in fact a
bunch of my startups already use Vimeo
Pro including wealthfront who uses it to
explain how wealthfront works TaskRabbit
uses it to tell their company's story
and there are many other names you would
recognize among their customers Airbnb
Etsy etc why do they use it well Vimeo
Pro provides enterprise level video
hosting for a fraction of the usual cost
features include gorgeous high quality
playback with no ads up to 20 gigabytes
of video storage every week
unlimited plays and views and a fully
customizable video player which can
include your logo custom outro etc you
also get VIP support and you get all of
this for just $1.99 per year that's $17
a month with no complicated bandwidth
calculations or hidden fees and you can
try it risk-free for 30 days so check it
out
Vimeo comm forward slash business that's
VI m EO com forward slash business and
use promo code Tim to get 25% off that's
a special discount just for you guys so
check it out
Vimeo com forward slash business promo
code tip and until next time thank you
for listening